(lowkey ambient music)
- Hey!
(upbeat music)
C'mon in!
Yes!
Push and Believe.
You got it!
Dan, during the commercial break
I was doing some
research, and thinking,
and I thought,
let's get away from
these questions,
from these PAs, from
these writers' assistants.
who give me this stuff.
- Great.
- Would you mind,
possibly, putting these on?
It might be a flashback for me.
- OKay.
- Wow, that's an uncanny
resemblance to my good friend
Zack Galifianakis
from The Hangover.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Be Zack.
Become Zack.
- No, this is,
that is something that
sounds horrible for me.
- Please be Zack.
- No, it's not.
- Please buy me lunch.
- I'm sorry you couldn't
book Zack for this show.
- Please take me out
to an Oscar party.
- I can't, I don't know.
- I wanna meet Bono.
- At best I could take
you to a Cable Ace Awards.
- All right, I can see that
you're getting irritated
with the glasses.
- Uh, yeah.
- Well take the glasses off!
- All right, there we go.
- So Dan, I have father issues,
and I read in your bio that
you too have father issues.
- Yes.
- Do you go to therapy?
- Not, I mean, not really.
- Do you do yoga,
do you exercise?
- Well, you know, I've been
trying to get into exercising,
but I really haven't.
I don't really know what to do.
- I'll tell you what I do.
Push-ups.
You just push up, push up,
you're pushing the pain,
and you're bringing
in the positivity.
Is your father still around?
- He's still around.
- You know, I wish I
could get him here,
fly him up here, get
him on the phone.
But that's not possible.
- No, what are we
gonna do instead?
- I say we get the table,
move it out of the way,
turn this interview
on its head!
- We're gonna do it!
- Yes!
- Yeah!
- Welcome to the Steven Brody
Stevens push up challenge
as I prepare for
dealing with my father.
So this is what I do.
I'll go first, and
then you can go,
then we'll do it tandem.
Head up, body straight.
- Yeah.
- P?
Pro, pro...
L
E
S
Daddy problems.
- That was great.
- You got it it.
- It's about your father,
it's not about you.
- All right, it's not about me.
- Go ahead, I'm here with you.
- Okay, thank you so much.
- I don't want your life, dad!
- Say it!
- I don't want your life!
- Believe it!
- Working out dad issues
while I'm working out!
- He can hear you from
Boston and New Jersey.
- Yes!
- Yell in that carpet!
- Can I do a new move where I
just get in a fetal position
and I start crying?
- You can, and I will hold you.
Dan, it's okay.
Dan, it's okay!
(crying)
Dan it's okay, it's okay.
- Making me feel good.
- It's okay.
Dan St. Germain.
Check him out,
half hour special.
Yes!
Push and Believe.
You got it!
(guitar riff)
♪ Click
♪ Like
♪ Subscribe
♪ Click
♪ And like it on Facebook.
♪ Like
♪ Subscribe
♪ Push
♪ Believe
♪ And like it on Facebook.
♪ Push
♪ Subscribe
♪ Believe
♪ Click
♪ And like it on Facebook
♪ What a great video
♪ I bet you liked it
♪ Subscribe
♪ Believe
♪ And like it on Facebook
♪ Subscribe
♪ What a great video
♪ I bet you liked it
♪ Believe
♪ And like it on Facebook
♪ Subscribe
Wooh!
(bathtub drains)